(pencil scribbling)
(gentle upbeat music)
- I think biology is so
critical for everybody to learn
because it defines who we are
as human beings, as animals.
It defines the whole animal kingdom,
and then it goes on to define
the whole plant kingdom,
the insect kingdom.
Understanding those principles
of how living things are organized
is not only a beautiful
thing to understand,
but it gives deep insight
and deep appreciation
for our own lives,
and I think that is the core
of why I find it so important
that everybody study this
beautiful area of academia.
- Biology is super important
to learn for so many reasons.
But the reason that stands
out most to me is, well,
the rarity of life outside
of our little corner of the universe.
You might not know what I mean,
but stick with me for a sec.
So we are positively surrounded
by biology every day here on Earth,
but we haven't encountered
life or even evidence
of life outside of this
little blue marvel,
even though there is so much
cosmic real estate out there.
Life is really complicated,
and that goes for starting
and sustaining life.
Somehow ancient organisms
made it work here,
but that doesn't mean that it's easy.
All of us carry on this
legacy of life finding a way,
but one day maybe life will
have to find a way through us.
Maybe Earth becomes
inhospitable for some reason
and we have to figure out
how to live somewhere else.
On that day, success will depend
on how well we understand the heaps
of obstacles that the stubbornness
of life has already overcome.